work accidents can happen at any time
but what are some things you should do
in case you're a victim of a workplace
accident eric palacios from eric
palacios and associates the sponsors of
this segment tells us more
welcome to the legal minute i'm attorney
eric palacios today we're going to tell
you three things you need to do if you
suffer a work injury
number one be sure to report it to a
supervisor immediately it's best to have
confirmation and this can be done with a
text or an email number two seek medical
attention as soon as possible although
you have 90 days to see a doctor the
longer you wait the worse it is for your
claim
number three tell the doctor or the
medical staff that you were injured at
work this way the doctors will fill out
the correct forms to protect your claim
this has been the legal minute don't
forget to download my app eric palacio's
legal app
and for more information you can give
eric palacios and associates a call at
702-444-7777 or visit them on their
website at ericpalacioslaw.com
we'll be right back